well the season celebrations aren't
quite over whether you are still
celebrating the holidays or getting
ready for new year's john marie abwan
chocolatier has you covered welcome to
the show i am so happy when anyone shows
up with this much chocolate thank you so
much for having me thank you so much for
being here so i don't even know where to
begin because i'm so distracted by how
beautiful all of your chocolate is but
let's talk a little bit about you said
you've been here for 10 years you have
quite the story yeah i opened this
company 10 years ago i was previously
the executive pastry chef in a bellagio
and i decided to to go on my home
because i love chocolate and then open
this company well with the holidays
still in full force here heading into
new year's kwanzaa is still here let's
talk about why these gifts might impress
your guests well we created a very very
special box actually it's one meter box
which is where we have 100 pieces inside
100 chocolates inside it's very very
unique it's a it's very elegant very
classy and we can have a hundred
different flavors inside the box as well
oh a hundred flavors of chocolate what
more could you want and okay i can't
continue this interview until i have a
bite of something and i saw you have a
whole sample over here so do you have
your favorite well all of them
good answer all of them are my favorite
but if you like a little bit nuts for
example this one this type of truffle
would be amazing or this one as well
okay okay you pointed to this one first
we're going in for this one what's this
one hazelnut is it not caramelized
processed in paste and after that we
covered in milk chocolate oh my god okay
and what's the proper way to eat it all
at once or take a bite
oh my gosh it melts in your mouth it's
amazing
okay as i'm eating this let's talk a
little bit about if people come to visit
you the types of things that they can
get in the store well we have we have a
lot of different type of boxes we have
24 pieces boxes we have 40 pieces boxes
we have of course 100 pieces boxes 16
pieces boxes as well over there we can
also create
actually the customer can create uh
their own box when they come to our
factory or place their order online as
well and we have a lot of different
options even caramels even um we won an
award with the new york times a few
years ago with a double sea salt caramel
and
there's a lot of lot of different
products and a lot of different
possibilities to build your boxes to
have a very very unique
chocolate gift oh my gosh well
congratulations on your awards and
everything you've done i'm still eating
this piece because it's so good and i
think it's so fascinating to see how
chocolates are made you guys make
everything in-house there or what's the
process we make everything in-house we
we select first of all the best
ingredients that we can find sometimes
organic vanilla from mexico or different
different flavor natural flavors from
everywhere around the world and after
that well it's a little bit skills a
little bit uh
test understanding triumph i mean we try
a lot of different things we tried a lot
of different new flavors and we also
balance between the colors and the
natural also color of the chocolate
there's um there's a lot of different
products that you can find in our uh in
our shop and um
i mean i just love chocolate it's my my
life it's it's what i do it's uh it's
what i like i eat chocolate every day
that was going to be my next question do
you eat it every day i don't think i
could work around it and not at least
have one piece a day well i have a
minimum of
actually eight pieces a day
okay so that's the standard amount eight
is okay today it is i like you i like
this idea it's only vitamin c i have
seven more to go so
please do okay why don't we try one of
these colorful ones because they're so
pretty okay um what do you prefer
berries um a little bit more fruity a
little bit more nutty i like the nuts i
think the nuts okay this is like a
fruity one i can go for that one yeah
fashion food
all right as i'm eating this because i
put the whole thing in my mouth last
time and i couldn't even talk
let's talk about can people still come
stop by the store can they just wander
in do you need to make appointments how
does it all work absolutely we have a
factory store that opens monday to
saturday actually from 9 a.m to 5 p.m
and people can see actually
all the staff working on the back and
creating the chocolate but also they can
test a lot of different chocolate that's
the really the beauty of the store it's
coming and testing different products
and after picking the one they want to
uh to build a box with and also online
we have our website
gm1 chocolates.com that they can place
orders and we can deliver the same day
in las vegas or we ship nationwide wow
that's amazing you can get it anywhere
but we're lucky that we have you right
here so you can come by and check it out
and this is delicious i have six more
pieces to go so i'm going to go do that
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much
i can vouch it's still